yeah we've had a lot more detail from
the Department of Defense about how they
shot this down and the way they shot it
down that's crucial to retrieving that
payload which we'll talk about this is
how it happened the balloon was at 60 65
000 feet the F-22 lower than that when
it fired the missile that brought this
balloon down where it landed is really
really key to this whole thing they
waited until it was over water but
within the 12 miles of United States
territorial water and also not too far
from the coast because that means there
was only 47 feet down this isn't two
scale so it is retrievable what are they
hoping to achieve and why was it put
here important here because Tom this is
shallow water it's a very narrow window
this water this shelf drops off pretty
quickly and so they only had a certain
amount of time to make sure it came down
here it looks as if they more or less
hit the bullseye and if it's only 50
feet down they will recover it they will
get it back now initially the Chinese
said this has been blown off course and
I want to show you a map after this
really that shows bubble is it might
make sense this is Stratosphere wind at
the altitude that bloom is out from the
earth null school
um you can see okay maybe there's not
much we can do about that the wind is
blowing a certain way we'll show you
this is a higher altitude see the winds
are going a different way so it looks
like you can choose your winds this do
you think this has really blown off
course no I mean balloons can go up and
down and they'll will change Direction
with the with the prevailing currents
even if it was off course the Chinese
have a duty in their case in that case
to bring it down before it goes into
anyone else's airspace well I mean the
latest statement from China is that it
was uh irresponsible an excessive
reaction from the United States to shoot
this down this is a video uh from just
doing the rounds on Chinese social media
from 2019 it shows a Chinese Jack going
up to shoot down a weather balloon
you'll see the remnants of that where
the balloon has a missile strike after
this there is a lot of theater here a
lot of posturing talk about this balloon
Gap as well but the serious point isn't
there about the technology rivalry
between China and the US what have we
learned from this yeah I mean what we
know is that any object in somebody
else's airspace can be shot down and if
you talk about China or America they
will tend to do that and there's a sort
of an interesting uh dynamic between
high-tech Jets like the F-22 and much
more simple balloons albeit with some
pretty high-tech stuff hanging below
them